nous voudrions vous emmener ce matin
dans un quartier général où se commande
tous les journaux télévisés régionaux
messieurs directeur à quand remonte ses
premiers journaux télévisés à ses très
loin l'automne 1963 l'île fut la
première servie puis vint le tour de
strasbourg marseille ou rouen un an plus
tard une multiplication des lucarnes
pour tout le territoire n'est ce pas
monsieur le directeur
notre règle d'or c'est la télévision ne
doit pas être une télévision fait à
paris pour les parisiens et par des
parisiens mais une télévision française
nous sommes le fils de radiodiffusion
télévision française le rtf et non pas
le rtp la télévision parisienne et ce
grand chef étant d'ascendance normande
il fallut bien un jour penser à caen ce
qui arriva au début de l'année 1966
quand ou plutôt sa voisine la modeste
bourgade de saint pons p pour des
raisons d'économie et rapidité
la technique avait choisi d'installer
des préfabriqués sur le terrain des
pylônes des émetteurs parce que c'était
à nous donc la parité le terrain
il salue construire équiper et recrue
est une petite équipe d'une vingtaine de
personnes
une gageure en ce temps-là faire venir
des gens qui acceptait de quitter leur
emploi c'était le plein emploi à
l'époque pour venir travailler là
c'était présidente puis il ya eu il faut
le dire aussi la résistance et de la
presse écrite qui craignaient que on
mettait la publicité sur ces journaux
régionaux de ça leur fasse une
concurrence économique d'abord éditorial
sécréter les préfectures
c'est vrai mais il faut se replonger
dans l'esprit de l'époque enfin
normandie une première c'est votre
première visite le centre de lag
vous êtes très satisfait je suppose et
sur le plan régional et même local
pourrait venir cela a beaucoup d'intérêt
chez ministre et puis le temps a passé
les images aussi la télévision des
régions est devenue une chaîne à part
entière en 1972 la troisième chaîne
couleur de l'eau et rtf baptisé fr3
trois ans plus tard la suite de ses
aventures serait trop longue
surtout vu deux camps cette petite
station de l'ancien basse normandie qui
a tant fait ton inventée
bonne nouvelle un j'ai les images de
traitement regardez le plaisir de
rencontrer jus et surtout tant compté
pour vous lancer la marine qui a pris le
relais
mesdames et messieurs de voir notre
premier journal télévisé nous espérons
vous retrouver chaque jour à notre
rendez vous bonsoir à demain